I have no idea he got this head to the
side as though considering it
maybe I am him maybe I'm not it's not
for me or you to know yet all will be
revealed at the appointed time what
should concern you at the moment is that
my current power situation makes the
question moot
so many powers at my disposal he said a
smile in his words how to best place you
into a proper state of all his earlier
friendly tone it morphed into a taunting
one should i levitate myself
he lifted off the ground about two feet
hanging there like a hummingbird or
shall I rain down fire from the sky
instinctively Henry jerked his head up
to the night sky several bright stars
were visible but no fireballs were
present after several seconds of nothing
I finally noticed one of the stars was
moving left to right ever so faintly no
sooner had I made this realization then
the thing sped up rapidly I began to
grew in size it was coming right for us
before I could process any of this the
fireball balloon he filled the air and
thundered into the cornfield to her left
with a furious crash flames immediately
danced up the stalks and spread across
the crop as though the entire field had
been previously doused in gasoline
Finch spoke again shape-shifting Henry
turned his wide eyes back toward the old
man in each of his open palms a fireball
appeared in a blue employment boat into
the other cornfield on our right
repeating the instantaneous blaze from
seconds earlier he started to grow in
height in size before we knew it he was
15 or 20 feet tall and entirely composed
of loud rippling tongues of fire his
shape we had to change anymore into
something much more terrifying
I was exactly accustomed to seeing fire
and through my distorted view of the
surroundings it looked like the coin
field around us was now completely
engulfed in flames the sharp rise in
heat was intense fingers of great horn
fire danced off the tops of the stalks
crackling hissing I was terrified do you
see that Henry's voice betrayed his fear
how could I not see them before us maybe
a hundred feet or so away is something I
can only describe it